Film Courage: Is there anything you want your
students to know before they start writing
a screenplay?
Paul Joseph Gulino, Associate Professor at
Chapman University Dodge College of Film and
Media Arts: Before they begin writing a screenplay
what should they know?
Is there anything they should know before
writing a screenplay?
Yes I guess there is one.
Am I passionate enough about this project
to spend six months on it?
Do I really care that much?
Because it’s going to be tough sledding
at some point.
In fact my old mentor had a couple of suggestions
[Frank Daniel].
I forget if I shared these?
He had a couple of interesting suggestions
for how to deal with when the going gets really
rough.
He said that when you get your inspiration
for this script and it’s going to be the
greatest script anybody ever wrote.
Then what you do it you type it out on a piece
of paper.
Type it out…we don’t do that.
Write it out on a computer and print it out
later - what your reviews are going to be,
what your speech is going to be at the Academy
Awards, what historians are going to say about
this script and how great it is.
Put all of that on a piece of paper and you
seal it in a envelope and you put it away
somewhere carefully.
Then when you’re writing it and you’re
in the middle of it and everything is bad.
Every scene you write tastes like yesterday’s
oatmeal.
Ah!
It doesn’t work and you say “I’m done.
I’m giving up.”
He said that is when you reach for your envelope
because it reconnects you with what that initial
inspiration was.
Now in my experience doing that I never reached
for…I was always like “What if that fails?
I better not reach for it.
I’ll keep going.”
But knowing it was there helped.
Ah!
That’s not working.
So before they begin are they passionate enough
about the subject matter to whether the pain
it’s going to cause to do it.
Film Courage: I like that idea.
So right when there is a spark and you’re
just so into it writing (not the script) you
are writing reviews, your acceptance speech,
you’re up there, you’re in your dress
or tux or whatever and you’re thanking everyone
and how [your script] has changed the course
of culture, whatever…
Paul: The culture of cinema.
Film Courage: Yes and then you keep that there
[the envelope tucked away]…wow interesting.
Great tool.
Paul: It is very interesting.
They also said don’t write to the edge.
When you’re writing scenes.
If you’ve got the idea of how the scene
will end don’t finish it…stop, make a
few notes about how you’re going to finish
it and that way when you pick up the next
day you’re not starting over again.
You’re like “Oh that’s where I was”
and you can pick up where you left off.
So never write all the way to where you never
have any more ideas.
Stop just before then and keep plowing ahead
to the next time.
So that’s something I do all of the time
to make sure I know what is coming next.
And he said don’t write if you’re not
excited.
Whatever your technique is whether you are
listening to music, getting up and pacing
around the room.
But get excited about what you are doing because
that will show through with what you’re
doing.
The passion comes through.